wait for three yes wait wait read that
screed perfectly loves get into that
left hand to clear a little space that
stuff at the cord just under two minutes
left in this third quarter wait with the
steel by yourself
I stutter step move and of a grater for
the score a precise feed from way ahead
by six just under 10 minutes deploy nice
cut Olynyk off the weight dish able and
feminine pretty Hornets lost track of
the Miami heats all-time leading scorer
that of Whiteside who's got nine points
now it's a high percentage score Reuter
to Travis game tied at 45 season
strictly an off the bench player for
Charlotte a good role for him good help
by Batum Wade for three commode laneway
tripling with more consistency this year
that defense that even Republicans
averaging almost eight points a game
this season good defense by Olynyk took
it away from peculiar Kelly on a Cooper
dishes for at waitwait Jam prettiest
play of the night for the youth getting
out on the break the seven footer
leading it fakes to his right foot
points heat ahead by four good defense
again the poked away creates another
Detroit turnover and Wade capitalizes
pretty action on both ends from I am
getting out on the break that taken
advantage of Detroit here comes Dwyane
Wade misses defense gets back way ducks
in looking for the fan instead gets a
long two that's what they're ruling it
right now Wade
stepping through after the ball fake
gets inside the three-point line this is
had Davis
wait block the shot by hollis-jefferson
here comes Lane look foul by Napier that
he had to come back see Hollis Jefferson
gather himself his timing impeccable
Larry open there on that open look nice
pass by Wade look out below the 36 tons
of the season for Hassan white shepherd
Terrence Ross and a draft Miller good
deal for the rafters good pump fake and
a chance at a three-point play between
Wayne interior that's one way to get
defenders up in the air head and
shoulder ball fake lean in draw the
contact are there for the open turbulent
second turnover in a row on my own limbs
pastor Collins intercepted by McGruder a
long lead to one category the Trey young
7 double doubles as a rookie to have
come against my own cup of water circus
shot by
360 spin a backhanded flip he has 11
when he turned my 15 weight out of the
post to Olynyk gets it back for the
turnaround accident the two shots five
points example of slowing it down now
and getting organized that offensive
possession and look what happens the
Heat are rewarded
perfect execution of when to push the
ball in the face and want to execute the
half-court execute well at the
half-court set right here can you wave
only space over here second foul on each
one or twin weight has been sinful
living off the heat bench tonight
Rubio hops over the top made it a tough
catch for waves Olynyk steps into a
three coming now four points off the
bench in a row for Olaf tinkles crafty
behind the back dribble in the crowd
from behind by Dwyane Wade your guard
Adam Bailen three-point lead for Utah
Wade evens the game
first triple the night left in the
fourth quarter Whiteside is back and
replacing Pam gets at least answer
please finishes that is country strong
for a satellite shot two-man game on the
wing pick and roll no-look pass and hits
him right on the hip area where he can
catch it right up to the bass five of
six shoot Lakers ahead by eight begins
wait bouncing for Pete Jackson up in it
kiyo has been an excellent finisher
magical game for justice Winslow SC
tonight 22 points
he's Titus New Holland forgeries way he
did a great home
[Music]
left-handed flip all tenant is going to
the second hand we're afraid to make a
change that may help his team I totally
agree particularly this zone defense
which I'm sure some fella will see is
the play though we hit him with the
Smitty
[Music]
[Applause]
places to its towns charge and Covington
upfront written a cookie black
lightweight way coming back this way
with Tyler Johnson Vinson known for
being a really good defender he's very
long at six nine
on the reverse setup Taj Gibson nice man
John Collins grabs the rebound booth
throws it back into Derek Jones looking
waters away and here's the pitch ahead
in the vision by Dwyane Wade Jones jr.
trailing behind and perfectly timed play
because we've got Bembry to commit to
him let's take another look memory
thought he was going to shoot the layup
that got him to commit left Derick open
for a full airplane mode from here
coming tie game a 61 weight gets it off
great chapter to end the first half at
Wade Wade jumper under duress scoring
half of justice Winslow's career 18
points in the first half for Winslow
into the mat with a man with 6 seconds
left
Dwyane Wade ties Shelvin Mack up when he
was talking about injuries he said not
excuses but they are reasons for up and
down stone nice play by Wade he also
draws the foul
second score for general tide leads the
heat with eat your suede underneath to
the score and the foul play took
advantage of Patrick Beverley parked him
in the lane and then put it in over it
using the size saw no shot blocker was
there he could sneak it up on the front
side of the rim
two minutes into the fourth wait brakes
ready for a ferocious done oh maybe a
party gift to the Cleveland fans who
supported him a year ago turnover easy
one here a little fake handoff type
action Wade kind of sweep that one in I
think that's why he's smiling right
there he was coming down when he made
that play so far again Wade faking
firing and finishing every twist and
turn of great footwork and underutilized
move watch the the pivot through the
defender and that Warriors going with
dreamer and klay Thompson DeMarcus
Cousins Shaun Livingston and Quinn cook
let's nicely play Jamie Johnson with his
first score of the game under three
minutes left third quarter thanks for
joining us here these three basketball
wait wait getting to the puck I like
lose Adachi
pastor Johnson while attacking on the
way to Twain with nine points away
weighed against Brussels three seconds
left in the head
got it Swain read as he rebounds and
five of it in this one here comes D on
setting up Dwayne Wade
basket will Cavanaugh a nice setup by
dion Waiters treat not only score but
set up his teammates here seeing the
streaking Blaine coming in here's the
lead pass the puck down wait wait he's
starting the second half able to dunk
here's curry for checking the dribble
flips it ahead hook it up
Durant for Wade's Walker back his wave
seven
[Applause]
it is you called it and here's off the
backward the old teammates back to bat
champion Miami Heat
wait and just hung up in the air before
giving it a chance putting it on the
glass steel by weight off a deflection
thirty seconds left in the quarter BAM
Mike one of the season ticket holders
remember season taking all their members
you can remove this week is member
appreciation week calendar way as we got
some
I'm going here for Mike we got to
reenact this one right here look at this
up and under it's always painful when
you plummet to the bottom it's tough
making your way back down
wait with the takeaway live in Laurens
analytic right over the shoulder catch
my researcher man he found Kelly
underrated team defensively they're so
good offensively weight with a seal
nobody home
[Applause]
[Music]
laid against Iguodala peril mph enemies
weight gets the three lane ten seconds
one raid against Iguodala five seconds
left
Raiders back to twin shoots no I
couldn't get it off now fires it up
[Applause]
1:26 to go
it just happened
at time let's take a closer look here on
your street totally off Baptist's off
the glass circus shot and weighed the
hero once again in his final game
against the Golden State Warriors Dwyane
Wade beats the worries he's off and
running stops at the three-point line
and wait comes away with a steal
racing with Lowry by Gasol
[Applause]
Sabitha for a whale
what a start for him coming off the
bench just instant spark three four it's
a big part of being a great defender
wage shooting the gap there Larry made
the cardinal sin of getting stuck up in
the air weight again slim euro steps for
the one hander it rolls him a fall
George second the James Harden in
scoring this year wait wait such a good
job always have momentum buddy win was
an abusive well the other thing Eric is
the turnovers he continued at first look
at another turnover 16 turnovers now
focusing with 21 points to 9
three seconds left in the quarter wait
for the pack by trade so we enjoyed this
number three leave them with another
memory 39% the Bucks just over 51% Wade
creeping closer and closer to Michael
Jordan's shot-blocking record for a
guard for twins
let's--oh had that the jump on of a
crate recovering the game this year
against the Heat including a 19 point 10
rebound game until he wound up with his
fourteenth done for this final season
flow Cygnus and of here hesitation
around green and then the finish step
back top shot
[Applause]
let's get into the left hand here after
the ball fake to create space stepping
back for again just got him on the wrist
elbow action
[Applause]
their coach
[Music]
to a rifle but one of the NBA's greatest
players ever it was beautiful to see and
feel weight response I'm Gordon a where
this year both are healthy and back and
they haven't feared nearly as well this
is been a chemistry issue not clicking
all together off the steel truck a table
the finish stop if they don't they're
not gonna be able to win the game town
scores it's a one-point game with ten
seconds to go bill
lobbying for a foul BAM Adebayo pulled
him out of trouble
look at Wade he looked off the defense
and brought the heat to will in a point
Johnson 35 Handley
we'd step back triple-double this
rockets with a shot clock drain again
corner three
[Applause]
with 21 points did by Wade that
triple-doubles going to happen that's
ten rebounds now for Wade Dwyane Wade
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content